with us yeah so I've seen a lot of
people asking for like to flaunt my odds
chide my rides all that but we need
videos don't just send in a picture or
and send it and four tried my ride don't
send in a picture of a car you see seen
on a street it's gotta be your car so
this is a chide my ride all right hey
boys I'm here to show off my ride this
is a 2007 Freightliner packaged car gang
and it comes stuck with this nice
diamond plate floor minsters my fridge
that's aftermarket though pay for that
myself
I feel like this man's living out of
this car also aftermarket this one's
pretty young she's only got four hundred
and ninety five thousand miles on
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing like when you're waiting for a
pack as you see that Brown [ __ ] hit or
pull up like oh hell yeah here he comes
put on some Cologne
that's a beautiful rod man that's really
this that every day Santa Claus right
there doing the Lord's work one package
at a time he said [ __ ] Amazon and it's
interesting to seeing how like yeah you
got a you bring your own stuff that
thing's pretty basic huh I think it's
just pretty run-of-the-mill
did he say I have his own radio in there
yeah so you bought all the aftermarket
starter so that's wild man thanks for
being out there bro on the front lines
dude so people can't [ __ ] you know
stuff yeah
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]